one reaction is this is not enough 10  000 is not enough 20 000 is not enough  fine  fine but this is already  overwhelmingly more than any other  president has done by far so as i've  said before  i tend to evaluate presidents based on  what they do  generally speaking and also for things  they promise to do  but don't do i think both are fair game  just saying well this president's bad  because he didn't do these 10 things  that he never promised to do  that seems to be a way to end up  with relatively meaningless evaluations  of presidents so  when you look at what joe biden has done  he has by far for given more student  that than any other president